Richardson Los Angeles welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Bridget hi Dave thank
you so much for taking my call my
pleasure
how can I help I do my husband I started
looking into debt and we have decided to
start tackling it and getting rid of it
as soon as possible all right I heard
about you through a co-worker and I this
past Saturday I was just hooked on your
podcast you know hearing people stories
and just learning how to you know best
do this we were able to scrape up about
10,000 from savings I have a side
business apart from my full-time job so
so many that I have there along with
like I was saving like in the corridor
count as well as our 401k so we're able
to scrape up about ten thousand dollars
there all of those methods we have about
fifteen thousand dollars in credit card
debt and we have thirteen thousand
dollar personal loan from the credit
union so my question is should we use
these funds to pay off one of these
debts or at least make a good you know
then and one of them and if so which one
should we tackle first for credit union
or their credit cards okay you have more
than one credit card right yeah one debt
that's one category of debts each card
is an individual debt okay and what we
teach folks to do is to list your debts
and baby step two after you've saved a
thousand dollars anything above a
thousand dollars not counting a
retirement
I would not cash out a 401k and I would
not cash out a Coverdale you didn't do
that did you don't just stop adding to
stop adding to them temporarily so how
much of the ten thousand that you're
counting is in a retirement account or a
college savings account that would be
about five thousand okay so you have
five thousand dollars in cash not
counting retirement College okay that's
what we're going to work with we're not
going to cash out your retirement or
your college because you're going to get
penalized and taxed on that and it's
going to hit you to the tune of thirty
to forty percent which is higher than
the interest you're paying so you
wouldn't do that
okay so I would stop adding to those do
you have Auto draft on your check or
checking account going into those
accounts yes I stopped doing that I
actually stopped it this weekend and
also we had like a whole life policy for
the kids I know I stopped that yeah well
can we will catch that out any little
bit of cash that's in that's fine we can
cash that out so what's your household
income it is a hundred and twenty eight
thousand per year great great okay so we
have a fight with five thousand dollars
cash and let's work the baby steps then
baby step one is save a thousand dollars
so that leaves us four thousand am i
right
right okay and we're gonna apply that to
your smallest debt down to your largest
debt and so what that's gonna do is
knock out your smaller credit cards
because the personal loan is one big
loan right right okay so you're gonna be
debt free and probably about a year or a
little less okay the only part that I
didn't that you know dave is that we do
have a require a mortgage on our
mortgage is about thirty three hundred a
month okay that's fine it's not that big
a deal you can here we tell folks trying
to get a mortgage more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay yours isn't shouldn't be
we should be right around there but it's
a little rich but it's not the end of
the world
now I'm not gonna panic and sell a house
I just want you on a written budget jump
on the jump online and get the every
dollar app it's free the budgeting app
and you and your husband okay did you
and your husband do the budget together
we did great well you are you're on fire
man you're on track you that's the thing
so did you feel like you got a raise
when you did the budget like where's all
this freakin money going that's a normal
feeling because what happens is when you
get organized you recognize the waste
and we all blow money when we don't have
a plan and when you have a plan you
suddenly go won't we have to stick to
the plan because we want to get out of
debt because we want our life back we're
gonna chop up these credit cards and
we're gonna pay them off in order well
get rid of this personal loan cuz we
don't have any payments life's gonna be
good right right yeah I do have one more
one more question for you Dave I do have
some
student loan debt it's about sixty
thousand it is differed right now but it
is going to start being due soon within
the next few months and so I have
already sent me notice where their terms
the payment per month is about 570 per
month but I was looking at my options
online so I can do the longer term so
it'll lower the payments about two
thirty per one to a longer time or
shorter term we're trying to get out of
that okay
okay cuz I thought about that using the
snowball effect not for adjusting among
guys right now your minimum payment
whatever the minimum they make you pay
is that's gonna slow down the numbers I
just gave you because I didn't know that
when we were talking about this so
you're not gonna be out of debt in a
year it's going to take you between two
and three okay
and you'll have no payments in but a
house payment that's gonna feel great
but you're gonna have no life during
that two to three years you're gonna be
on beans and rice rice and beans kiddo
well you know the house will be worth it
we've got a pool so oh well you got you
got your entertainment then you're
staying home so you know what do you
want to do today or swimming in the pool
what do you want to do tomorrow we're
swimming in the pool what do you want to
do on Saturday we're swimming in the
pool you got your entertainment kiddo so
let's get out let's get after it now and
clean it up this is good